all right before we get started i do
want to thank the sponsor of this video
this video is brought to you by
satisfied they sent me the rise pads for
my ps5 controller and though this is
absolutely definitely not a ps5 flex
video
they have rise pads for switch
playstation xbox or whatever your poison
they got you covered they're easy to
install too i would call it an install
but it's more or less an easy snap done
but as easy as that is it doesn't feel
like they're gonna slip off the left
stick's a swivel stick which is
remarkably comfortable and satisfying
but also doesn't compromise any of the
accuracy and comes with an assortment of
five that you can mix and match for your
comfort always appreciate when a
company's like it's okay you don't have
to cut back on gaming we'll just make
you more comfortable so click the link
below head over to satisfied.com pick
yourself up a pair they're running a
special right now of free shipping enter
promo code jeremy 5 to take an
additional five percent off your order
and thank you once again to satisfy for
sponsoring this video i do appreciate it
and now heat up that crock pot tonight's
special is that member berry soup
[Music]
so ghostbusters afterlife is directed by
jason reitman who's the son of director
ivan reitman who directed the original
ghostbusters movie and ghostbusters 2.
so here's the premise of this movie
ghostbusters afterlife stars mckenna
gray she plays this girl whose
grandfather died grandpa left her in the
family this big creepy house in the
middle of nowhere it's on this farm that
doesn't grow anything so they all go to
live there they find a lot of grandpa's
old weird tech and now this ghost
apocalyptic event is gonna happen in a
small town in the middle of nowhere so
all the kids gotta get together and they
gotta stop it
and it's a ghostbusters sequel this
movie has a very different tone and you
just gotta know that going in i found
myself comparing this movie to
ghostbusters when i first came out of
the movie theater but just it's not fair
i was like oh well ghostbusters had a
lot better pacing but i mean
ghostbusters is to me the gold standard
of great pacing in a movie the first
half hour you meet the cast you meet the
crew all the characters are very
different they're distinctly different
they play off of each other in that way
they start their business they're
busting their first ghost slimer first
30 minutes ghostbusters afterlife it
takes the kids that first hour of the
movie to bust their first ghost you know
so it's a bit different but you look at
jason reitman and ivan reitman's movies
they are very different you know jason
reitman has the reitman name but their
filmographies are very different this is
jason reitman does a ghostbusters movie
and sometimes it works sometimes it
doesn't but for the most part it doesn't
work as much when it's trying to remind
you hey by the way ghostbusters throw
some ghostbusters references on the
screen but right out the gate gonna give
props mckenna grace is fantastic in this
movie you empathize with her she's the
nerdy little outcast kid who loves
science she's solving the puzzle she's
kind of a one-person mystery machine
which i mean you had enough to fill the
mystery machine so it didn't need to be
that way i'll get to that in a second
talk about how some of the other
characters didn't have much to do but
she's a fantastic actor who's done a lot
of good stuff before you're going to
continue to see her pump out more great
work i heard she's taking a break
after ghostbusters afterlife if i
remember correctly so i'm about healing
up um from back problems for carrying
this entire movie on her shoulders
actually that's not fair there's a
couple other characters in here i like
the kid that she befriends in this movie
podcast played by logan kim his name is
podcast cause he does have a podcast i
thought they worked well together i
thought they were a good team a good duo
very good for a two-person goonies going
out there and doing the ghost thing also
paul rudd
good for him people magazine sexiest man
alive that's right not captain america
ant-man and actually paul rudd's
sarcastic humor and mckenna grace's very
dry sense of humor they worked well
together too i don't even care she has
some jokes some dad jokes in here movies
telling me i'm not supposed to think it
was funny but
i'm an old soul i mean
obtuse that was pretty good the bummer
is there a lot of other characters in
this movie i didn't care about finn
wolfhard i love finn wolfhard but he
wasn't given much to do it was like oh
we got the stranger things kid in this
ghostbusters movie so put him over there
so we can give himself something to do
before we need warm bodies to fill up
those jumpsuits for the last act all
right perfect same with the girl who
plays his girlfriend i just i just felt
like they were like oh we just need two
people and of course it has to be a
romance because teenagers right at the
center of this whole thing it is a
family drama and that's the jason
reitman thing as jason reitman does
ghostbusters which is why in thinking
about this movie if this movie was able
to just be its own thing like maybe
jason reitman makes this movie unrelated
to ghostbusters about this absentee
grandfather who died and left his family
his weird creepy house in the middle of
nowhere and then the kids find grandpa's
weird creepy ghost tech and they find
out this super ghost apocalypse is gonna
happen in this town in the middle of
nowhere so they have to stop it that
would actually be a really cool movie
and when this movie looks like it's
going to be that it's actually it starts
excelling but it's never allowed to
excel enough because the movie it's like
it gets scared and it's like ah people
are forgetting it's a ghostbusters movie
quick throw the references and it's
comical how many ghostbusters references
are in this movie kind of reminds me of
you know when you watch a transformers
movie and you're just inundated with
product placement it's kind of like that
only it's ghostbusters references which
in its own way is product placement and
ghostbusters afterlife lean so heavily
on the ip of ghostbusters the
ghostbusters movie that came before it
the nostalgia bait was just to the
movie's detriment it wasn't leading you
in a way that was like all right what's
the secret behind the mystery why is
seismic activity happening what's
happening on the mountain no it's like
oh are we going to see the entire logo
of the ecto oh are you getting bored
here's a bunch of cute little stick puff
marshmallow men you know i'll give you
that one they're cute which is that
smart marketing your mascot trash new
york
you didn't rebrand why is vince cloretho
eating dog food he's not a dog not
really this movie feels like it has two
different identities like it's of two
minds on one hand you have what could
have been a compelling family story
among a great ghost adventure and on the
other hand you have very familiar very
cheap member berry stew that we've been
spoon fed for the past few years because
in the end i wanted to like this movie i
walked out of the movie theater i'm like
please find a
it's ghostbusters dude you know this hit
me and
it sounds perfect in my head so i'm
going to say it here and this isn't a
jason reitman ivan reitman comparison
because it's a parental comparison it's
not necessarily what i'm doing but
talking about ghostbusters afterlife the
movie it felt like a date that ended
with me knowing more about the date's
parents than i do about them in the end
maybe it's a better time if you're drunk
yeah who you gonna call he-man
deep cuts baby all right so ghostbusters
after life have you seen it what did you
think about it whatever you thought
comment below let me know and as always
if you like what you've seen here and
you want to see more click right here to
see more
[Music]
you